there have been even more new
accusations against Harvey Weinstein
more than 60 women are now accusing the
disgraced Hollywood movie producer of
sexual misconduct this as the television
Academy overwhelmingly decided to begin
disciplinary proceedings against
Weinstein which could result in the
termination of his membership donated
copal has more it's only good morning
good morning the accusations against
Harvey Weinstein continue to pile up on
Friday we learned about the Los Angeles
- please Police Department's criminal
investigation into an alleged sexual
assault in 2013 involving Weinstein
attorney Dave ring represents the 38
year old Italian actress who claims
Harvey Weinstein raped her in a Los
Angeles hotel room in 2013 her greatest
regret is opening that door but she had
no idea what was coming
ringg says his client who has chosen to
remain anonymous was in town for the los
angeles italia Film Festival Weinstein
reportedly bullied his way up to her
hotel room she never reported it to the
LAPD right after it happened she was
scared to death she felt horrible
she just didn't know what to do you know
she did not live here the LAPD's Robbery
Homicide Division is investigating the
alleged incident he was sitting so close
to me on this couch I started to get a
sick feeling in my stomach
former actress Heather Kerr also spoke
out on Friday
she says she was in her 20s and an
aspiring actress when she met the famous
producer Kerr claims during a business
meeting in 1989 Weinstein unzipped his
pants and forced her to touch him he
said name anyone any actress you can
think of and this is how they made it he
told me that first I would have sex with
him and then he would take me to parties
and show me who I needed to sleep with
after that Kerr says shortly after the
incident she quit pursuing acting as a
career I felt so powerless because he is
after all very powerful and very
well-known I didn't think anyone would
believe me I was nobody
why would they the attorney representing
Heather Curtis as numerous other women
who say they were sexually victimized by
Weinstein have asked her to represent
them
currently police in New York and London
are also looking into allegations of
sexual misconduct by Weinstein who has
continued to deny at this point any
non-consensual sex do we have a sense of
where Harvey Weinstein is at this point
not a very clear sense other than
therapy trying to get better he's lost
his career he's lost his job he's lost
his family his freedom maybe next Wow
thanks for that Tony